I think the most famous piece of writing
advice that there is is right what you
know,
and I think it's honestly,
I think it's the best piece of advice
there is,
but I think it is the most
misunderstood,
most mistaught,
most misinterpreted piece of advice that
there is.
It's so simple and so obvious.
And I used to terrify me this idea of
write what you know,
I was dreaming.
I was in Suburbia,
you know,
in my house,
dreaming of being a writer and I
thought,
what am I going to do with.
Right?
What,
you know,
what I know from childhood is I was on
the couch watching TV,
so I should simply rewrite a whole
series of sitcoms for you.
I should write a book called what's
happening and then I should write a book
called Little House on the prairies on
at 5:00.
You know what I'm saying?
This is,
that was my childhood experience and
this didn't feel to me when I thought of
the books that I love and that kind of
stuff I wanted to write.
It felt like I am going to be very
limited by.
Right.
What I know,
you know,
this idea like,
oh my family history,
we don't,
you know,
I'm very American.
I don't know my family history.
That's something that I,
it,
you know,
in the new book I wrote a story about
that very idea,
but I don't know,
my family history.
And,
and to me as a kid out in suburbia,
that wasn't the most thrilling life,
you know,
that's part of the central part of
growing up for those of us who were like
disenfranchised suburban kids,
was wanting to leave that town or that
world or that house,
you know,
I love you mom.
But nonetheless,
you know,
like so,
so for me,
when I thought about right,
where,
you know,
when I really thought about it,
understood like what it is is empathic
advice.
It's advice about feeling,
you know,
most of the books that we truly love
don't exist because these things did not
happen to the people that were writing
them.
But why do we love those books?
Why do they change this?
Why do they touch our hearts?
Why do they hold so much meaning?
Because they are truer than truth.
Because there is a great knowing within
them and I think what's behind,
right?
What you know is emotion.
Like have you known happiness?
Have you ever been truly sad?
Have you ever longed for something?
And that's the point is if you've longed
for an Atari Twenty 600 as I did when I
was 12,
you know,
like all I wanted was that game console.
Know what I'm saying?
If you have felt that deep longing,
that can also be a deep longing for a
lost love or for liberation of your
country or to,
you know,
reach Mars,
that's the idea.
If you've known longing than you can
write longing.
And that's,
you know,
that is the knowing behind,
right?
What,
you know.